[Music]
bra we got news today about bronnie or
you got news I'm sure what was your
reaction to hearing that um and and does
it sort of feel I obviously there's
still steps that have to be made and
stuff like that but this feels like the
biggest one that's been made yeah
absolutely absolutely um just I mean
obviously you seen a press relas but
just a proud moment Big Time excitement
from our family for bronnie um you know
and now for USC as well you know um this
is something that he's been working
towards for the last 12 weeks and um you
know for to him to um get the clearance
uh for him to do what he loves to do and
go back to you know being back with his
teammates and you know putting on a
uniform and things of that
nature um it's it's very gratifying for
sure this was obviously always the the
hope that it could get to this but were
you always sure it would um when
something that scary happens you just
put it in God's hands man and just trust
it that's it you know we we prayed as a
family um you you know we had great
doctors along the way the whole time
telling us that um you know they believe
things will you know work out for us in
our in our favor um you know so um and
bronnie took care of his business he did
everything and um didn't have any
setbacks didn't try to rush the process
of his rehab uh he took every step um
accordingly to plan and uh you know for
him to you know get that like I said get
that get that clearance to over the last
48 hours was was a big time for him
spoking about just how Amed you've been
by his Poise and his maturity through
this process as a father if this
continues in the right direction there
should be some Joy on the other side how
much are you looking forward to just
having him being able to have basketball
you know kind of pay it back um the way
he's given given himself to basketball I
mean that's his that's his passion and
his Joy you know his family his friends
and and the game of
basketball U he loves playing it he
loves
competing um he loves being out there
just having a good time having fun he's
been doing it for a long time and you
know he's put the work in and uh and
know it'll be be exciting um you know
looking forward to his first game
whenever whenever he's cleared and
whenever he's ready to have his first
game um I already told my teammates um
that if they play on the same day we
playing then I'm going have to catch
them next game so yeah I told you I told
you on the
plan family over everything Champs I
love y'all uh I definitely got to see
Bron's first you know his college game
um whenever he's cleared and ready to go
how much different is it as a just a
father kind of go through this and
seeing adversity you know for your son
relative to whatever you would experienc
before that point and and like what have
you kind of learned about yourself and
him in that
process
um yeah I mean when you go through
something like this then you really I
mean it just puts everything in
perspective and and truly understand
that nothing else matters besides you
know your loved ones um at that moment
you you just stop everything that you're
doing and it's literally you know how do
we
help him or help your loved one get
better from from the moment that it
happens all the way until you know you
know they're successful and it's still
not it's not like it's over know we
still have to continue to to monitor
every situation and you Contin to be
responsible in things of that nature um
but you know you know you just have an
opportunity to kind of just take a step
back from your own personal life and
give it all to to that IND
is